bonjour merci nous avoir invités
pourquoi
aujourd'hui sur l'événement donc moi je
suis invité en tant que la third adama
traoré
donc je sais pas si les personnes qui
sont la danse théâtre connaissent
l'histoire et la faire adama traoré
donc je vais en parler en tout cas ce
qui nous emmène à ici ça fait trois ans
nous sommes presque à trois ans de lutte
trois ans de combat pour la vérité et la
justice pour adama traoré
je suis obligé de vous raconter dès le
début ce qui s'est passé pour vous
puissiez comprendre mon frère va se
faire tuer le jour de son anniversaire
mon affaire va mon frère va certes eu et
le jour de ses 24 ans par trois
gendarmes
trois gendarmes qui vont amener la moire
mon petit frère et qui vont décider que
mon frère n'allez pas à vivre ce jour là
la journée de mon petit frère commencé à
10 heures du matin je vous parle de
cette pièce d'identité parce qu'elle
aura une place très importante dans la
suite de la mort de mon petit frère
la mairie va appeler chez nous pour dire
que mon frère puisse venir récupérer sa
pièce d'identité
malheureusement ce jour-là à damas n'a
jamais le temps d'aller la chercher
c'est un jour il faisait beau il faisait
plus de trente degrés il avait son
bermuda sa chemise à fleurs sont bob
il avait juste envie de faire un tour de
vélo et n'a pas été chercher son gilet
pare balles il n'a pas été chercher son
bouclier
parce qu'il faut savoir que en france
ici la pièce d'identité
et comme un gilet pare-balles et
considéré comme un bouclier
ce jour là mon frère ne l'avait pas et
il est mort parce que mon frère a subi
un contrôle au faciès vous savoir que la
france a été condamnée
or le contrôle au faciès parce qu'elle a
été reconnue ce jour là mon frère et mes
petits frères va subir un contrôle
d'identité alors ils vous parlent ils
ont mis tous mes petits frères en prison
on va revenir sur cette machine de
guerre comment l'état a fait en sorte
pour briser et camoufler la mort de mon
petit frère
c'est mon petit frère subi un contrôle
d'identité ce jour-là et adama passant
des lots et quand ils voient ces
gendarmes
il n'a pas ce qu'on bouclier il n'a pas
son gilet pare balles il n'a pas cette
pièce d'identité qui aurait pu lui
sauver la vie
faut savoir que la pièce d'identité a
été créé au moins de l'esclavagé que à
l'époque quand un esclave sortez dans la
rue qui n'avait pas sa pièce d'identité
en avait le droit de l'abattre en 2016
on a abattu mon frère parce qu'il
n'avait pas sa pièce d'identité et mon
frère il est mort l'interpellation de
mon frère va se rendre de temps
un premier temps a à peine de 200 m mon
frère ma soeur violentée par les
gendarmes à faire frapper un individu va
venir sauver mon petit frère parce que
les gendarmes sont en civil et
l'interpellation frères la courir et se
cacher dans un appartement d'une
personne qui connaît et tout va se
passer dans cet appartement mon frère va
subir un plaquage ventrale mon frère va
apporter plus de 250 kg sur lui ce que
je vous dis là parce que les gendarmes
ont dit lors de leurs premières
auditions le jour même mon frère va leur
dire je n'arrive plus à respirer ils
vont compressé mon frère ils vont
écraser la cage thoracique de mon petit
frère
s'il faut savoir que ce sont des
militaires ils étaient lourdement armés
et qu'ils étaient là pour apporter qui
sont là pour apporter secours pour sûr
toute vie humaine sur terre
à ce jour là il aura un droit de mort
sur la vie de mon petit frère
ils vont prendre à damas ils vont mettre
du ska dans ce véhicule dans la voiture
dans une q la dame avait uriné sur lui
il va piquer sur les va piquer de la
tête et ils vont pas l'emmener à
l'hôpital
il était à peine de 200 mètres il y aura
un droit de mort sur sa vie ils vont
aller le jeter dans cette cour de
gendarmerie où ils vont nous dire que
ils vont lui apporter les premiers soins
sauf que quelques jours après on va voir
que c'est faux ce qu'il faut c'est que
les gendarmes n'ont jamais apporté aucun
son à mon petit frère parce qu'il va
manquer les rapports des pompiers et des
samu dans le dossier notre avocat maître
yassine vous on va les exigé et si les
rapports vont dire que quand ils
arrivent dans cette gendarmerie à damas
avaient les menottes aux poignets ventes
contre le sol et que aucun soin lui est
apportée il n'était pas en position de
thales donc aux impossibilités de lui
apporter les soins
les gendarmes vont demander à ces
gendarmes retirer les menottes les
premiers vont dire non les gendarmes
vont insister vont dire c'est un jeune
homme de 24 ans on ne peut pas le
laisser mourir
retirer les menottes la mort officielle
de mon frère est déclarée à 19h05
on va faire court sur cette journée
parce qu'elle est très très longue
on écrit un livre qui s'appelle lettre à
damas où on parle en tout cas de ce qui
s'est passé ce jour là je trouve
alentours de 20 heures quelqu'un va
venir interpellé un des frères est dire
qu on a entendu dire que ton frère afr
malaise
ma famille va se rendre à l'hôpital il
n'y a pas d'âme à mon frère va appeler
les pompiers qui valait basculer
directement vers cette gendarmerie est
arrivée à la gendarmerie
ma mère passionnée elle va dire j'ai
entendu je recommande fissa et phare
malaise on va le dire madame votre fils
il va très bien
les pas le voir et fêtards on va lui
apporter notre petit frère va apporter
308 vers les alentours de 21h15 les
gendarmes on prend les sandwichs sauf
que chez nous c'est une toute petite
ville j'espère qu'un jour vous aurez
l'occasion de venir parce que nous
faisons plusieurs mobilisations emon et
nous allons faire la troisième marche en
juillet c'est une ville de moins de
10000 habitants
il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde et le
bruit bassir courir il se passe quelque
chose de pas normal à la gendarmerie de
personnes toutes les villes limitrophes
vont venir aux alentours de 23 heures
mon petit frère et yacouba qui est
aujourd'hui en prison pour savoir
combien on vient le chercher en prison
un an après parce qu'il a mis son pied
devant la porte de la gendarmerie et
qu'il a demandé à rentrer on va
l'accuser de intrusion de violence sur
les gendarmes et il est toujours en
prison
mon frère va mettre son pied il va
rentrer un gradé va leur dire il va
avoir un gradé va dire est ce gradé on
veut voir à damas le gradé va dire
rentrée si on vous dit quelque chose
est-ce que vous avez pas mal le prendre
bien évidemment ma famille va dire non
parce que pas une seule seconde on pense
à la mort et là on va dire qu adama
traoré il est mort voilà comment ça se
passe je vous raconte le début parce que
ses débuts là c'est ce qui va faire tout
tout tout tout l'histoire jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ce qui fait qu'on continue à
se battre
pas tout de suite la famille traoré on
va se lever et on va et on va demander
justice et vérité moi j'étais en croatie
j'étais pas j'étais parti un jour avant
les derniers échanges que j'avais vu
avec mon frère c'était le 18 juillet
quand j'avais déposé mes enfants à
aspères à beaumont sur oise
je l'avais appelé j'avais vu tous mes
petits frères sauf lui et je les
appelais nous on est à 50 km de beaumont
de paris et il m'a dit ah je suis déjà
parti à paris si tu veux je reviens je
lui dis non je pars on soit on verra la
semaine prochaine
et moi j'étais pas là quand ça s'est
passé je suis arrivé le lendemain le 20
juillet et tout de suite on va parler de
cette machine de guerre parce que c'est
depuis trois ans on se bat face à cette
machine de guerre qui n'a ni sentiments
qui n'a ni états d'âme qu'il admire aux
morts où tous les coups sont permis
où tous les coups sont permis ils ont la
puissance avec eux ils ont la justice
avec eux ils ont l'état avec eux ils ont
l'argent avec eux elle s'acharne sur
nous depuis presque trois ans mais on
continue à se battre face à cette
machine de guerre qui va criminaliser
mon frère les gendarmes ne seront pris
des criminels mais vont devenir
les victimes mon frère va devenir le
coupable alors qu'il est mort la famille
traoré va devenir la famille de mafia et
on va dire non et tout de suite on va
inventer des maladies à mon frère dès
l'octroi dès le troisième jour on va
dire qu adama traoré morts de causes
cardiaques des infections très grave
sous l'emprise de l'alcool et de la
drogue et c'est ce qu'ils font c'est ce
qu'ils font systématiquement depuis
plusieurs années dès qu'il ya un
problème avec la police et la
gendarmerie
tout de suite on criminalise la victime
l'état va automatiquement se mettre du
côté des forces de l'ordre et tout de
suite ils vont et tout faire pour un
espèrent un non-lieu
sauf que ceux là ils se sont pris à la
mauvaise famille est là on va dire non
et il faut savoir que trois jours après
lors de la première autopsie
quand on va aller voir mon petit frère
le soir même on va nous convoqué à la
préfecture de cergy pontoise et on va
nous dire la famille traoré nous savons
que vous êtes des musulmans que dans la
religion musulmane vous enterrer le
corps dans les trois jours on s'est
permis de contacter l'aéroport roissy
charles de gaulle et la compagnie air
france le corps la dame à traoré peut
partir dès demain que toute personne
souhaitant un passeport un passeport
leur sera remis tout de suite il y avait
une femme autour de la table et on va le
regarder on va dire non respecter nous
nous sommes aussi français à damas il
est aussi prend assez sera peut-être
enterré en france parce que cette
machine de guerre ne voulait pas qu'on
puisse demander 7 contre autopsie et on
va demander cette contre autopsie
tout de suite après mais comme nous
sommes dans un pays qui se dit liberté
égalité fraternité
elle ne peut pas parler d elle parle de
est liberté égalité fraternité parce
qu'elle a conscience qu'une très grosse
partie de sa population ne sait pas
utiliser ces droits correctement moi la
première
donc quand on ne peut pas utiliser ces
droits correctement en fait ce qu'on
veut nous aujourd'hui on dit que nous
sommes dans un état anti démocratique
parce qu'on se bat pour demander justice
et vérité et on nous met en prison parce
qu'on s'est levé et on va là cet état ce
qui va fait ce que va faire elle va
envoyer le corps de mon petit frère tout
de suite chez nous et des militants qui
vont être avec nous des familles de
victimes
on dire attention à la famille traoré
surtout ne prenez pas le corps de votre
frère si vous prenez le corps de votre
frère vous ne pourrez plus faire de
deuxième autopsie
on va avoir un geste violent et on va
dire on va repousser le corps de mon
frère et on va dire on n'en veut pas et
on va exiger cette deuxième autopsie qui
va dire qu'il va sortir une semaine
après qui va dire qu adama traoré n'est
pas mort de cause car jacking avec son
très grave ici l'emprise de la halle
cole mais c'est l'emprise de la drogue
et on va continuer à se battre avec
notre avocat on va demander à ce que le
procureur yves jannier qui a menti et
depuis le début soit déssaisi de
l'affairé serait dessaisi de l'affairé
va être muté
on va demander à ce que la sphère soit
dépaysée la ferme est dépaysé il va
arriver à paris en sept ans janvier 2017
et on continue à se battre mais il faut
savoir que tout ça quand on se bat ce
tout ça se passe en un mois ça a été un
mois très intenses mais à la machine de
guerre elle va taper très fort tout de
suite et elle va mettre les petits
frères en prison qui aujourd'hui en
prison pour tentative d'assassinât sur
les forces de l'ordre
quand mon frère et moi réalité révolte
chez nous il est des vols pendant
plusieurs jours ils vont mettre plus de
25 jeunes dans notre quartier on ils
vont faire une extermination de quartier
ils vont faire des interdictions de
séjour aux jeunes de nos quartiers pour
casser la mobilisation
aujourd'hui j'ai quatre de mes petits
frères en prison depuis le début et ils
vont les mettre un parent à 1 et petit
frère le tout premier il va demander aux
gendarmes et pourquoi vous faites tout
ça on n'a rien fait et on leur dira ta
soeur a fait trop de bruit qu'elle se
taise et mon frère et va dire à l'avocat
ya ma famille surtout battez vous ne
lâchez pas nous sommes en prison mais
continuez à vous battre pour adama et
ils vont mettre le deuxième en prison
ils vont mettre le troisième en prison
ils vont mettre le quatrième en prison
et le cinquième et a échappé il ya
quelques jours il était au tribunal de
versailles à trois jours on a eu de la
chance
là on s'est dit c'est une chance qu'on a
jamais eu ces deux à lui en prison
devant le tribunal et ne pas y ressortir
ben voilà comment cette machine de
guerre s'acharne sur nous parce qu'on en
a décidé de se lever et de demander
justice et vérité parce qu'ils n'ont pas
l'habitude non pas d'habitude que ça se
passe comme ça on écrit un livre qui est
sorti un deux semaines qui s'appelle
combat à damas on a décidé de l'appeler
combat à damas et pour nous c'est comme
un contre manuel sont contre manuel on
l'a écrit paul pour le parce que l'état
un manuel en face d'eux en face de nous
c'est manuel c'est que à chaque fois
qu'ils auraient une victime à chaque
fois qu'une personne va mourir mais ils
vont sortir ce manuel et vous regardez
page par page dans com qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on va criminaliser la famille on va
mettre une maladie à la famille on va
prendre le corps on va envoyer le corps
babacar gaye à rennes s'est fait tué de
sept balles dans le corps parce qu'ils
ont fait
suite ils ont convaincu la famille
d'envoyer le corps le corps est parti au
sénégal sans aucune autopsie
voilà ce qui est écrit dans leur contre
manuel et quand on écrit le combat le
livre combat à l'ama ont décidé de dire
nous aussi on va faire ce contre manuel
ils n'ont jamais eu de compte remanier
en face de nous on va le faire pas à pas
à travers le combat à damas comment
parler de ce pouvoir comment ce pouvoir
va tout faire pour nous emmener sur des
non-lieux comment ce pouvoir va se
partager les tâches
comment l'état la justice le procureur
les juges le les gendarmes les policiers
chacun ils saturent tous autour d'une
table et chacun va se partager le gâteau
est de dire à chacun va prendre un rôle
qu est ce qu on va faire comment va se
distribuer les tâches pour nous emmener
vers un non lieu
quand on voit qu'avec mon frère nous
sommes à la cinquième expertise la
cinquième expertise la première
expertise comme je vous ai dit va nous
parler de cause cardiaque et
d'infections très grave de la drogue et
d'alcool la deuxième expertise va
écarter les causes cardiaques une
infection très grave et il alcool et la
drogue
mais la juge va nous demander encore une
complet un complément d'expertisé ne
sais pas pourquoi est ce complément
d'expertisé va arriver un an après parce
que nous sommes dans le déni de justice
la justice joue avec la montre voilà ce
qui est créé non dans ce coup dans leurs
manuels dorment annuel ils vont prendre
du temps des affaires vont prendre dix
ans des affaires vont prendre quinze ans
pour épuiser la famille pour jouer avec
la montre et là nous on va on va taper
on va aller dans la rue parce que le
comité à damas ce qui va se passer
systématiquement c'est que à chaque fois
qu'il y aura quelque chose on va aller
se mobiliser en balles dans la rue et on
va les dénoncer le déni de justice qui a
dans la sphère adama traoré plus de 1,1
en aucun acte n'avait été demandée hélas
troisième expertise va sortir en
septembre 2018 et pour tout la première
fois il y aura écrit que pour toute la
première fois pardon il y aurait une
experte en cardiologie qui va dire que
adama traoré avait un coeur en pleine
forme que s'il avait un coeur en tant
qu'athlète l'écrit noir sur blanc une
experte en infectiologie va dire qu
adama traoré n'avait aucune infection
très grave mais on va aller chercher ce
côté raciste parce qu'il faut on va le
chercher des maladies exotiques des
maladies très rares que seules les
personnes qui viennent d'ailleurs
connaissent on va dire qu adama traoré
mort de drépanocytose
voilà c'est ce qu'ils vont sortir et que
comme mon frère avait couru 480 m en 15
minutes
mathématiquement c'est impossible ils
sont même pas appuyer sur les vidéos où
mon frère a fait deux minutes deux
minutes et voilà comment ils vont faire
leurs conclusions
car la matra aurait est mort de de
drépanocytose on va aller dans la rue on
va dénoncer encore 7 ce système
judiciaire qui veulent nous emmener sur
un non-lieu et on va tout de suite porté
plainte contre la première expect
expertes
c'est la première fois que ça se fait
dans dans des affaires de violences
policières
une plainte contre les expertises parce
que les juges se cache derrière les
experts elles ne vont pas faire leur
travail elles vont dire ce sont pas nous
qui l'avons dit les experts l'ont dit
donc nous allons amener vers un non lieu
donc on va porter plainte contre la
première experte qui va parler de crise
cardiaque et de lui demander pourquoi
comment se fait-il qu'elle écrit une
maladie cardiaque sur la mort de mon
frère avait être convoqué en janvier
2019 et elle va devoir répondre devant
les ordres des médecins parce que nous
avons demandé à ce qu'elle soit dessaisi
est que ce soit radiée pour pour le fait
qu'elle a écrit elle va nier l aéro
convoqué au mois de janvier devant 24
grands médecins pour qu'elle puisse
rendre des comptes et l'heure nous
attendons à la réponse et nous a aidé
nous avons les juges qui voulaient nous
emmener sur un non-lieu qui vont
convoquer les gendarmes et qui vont
poser aucune question sur les violences
causées sur la mort et qui vont orienter
les questions et qui vont aller sur la
non assistance en personne en danger
parce que comme le pouvoir se partagent
ces tâches ce pouvoir va se dispatcher
les charges pour que personne ne prenne
la responsabilité
les experts nous écrire un tissu de
mensonges les juges vont statuer sur
cette expertise là
le procureur va venir parler au nom des
gendarmes et des policiers et les
gendarmes vont être acquitté voilà
comment ça se passe sauf que la famille
traoré va demander une contre expertise
encore une fois qu'on va payer de notre
propre poche parce qu'il faut savoir que
de l'autre côté nous sommes les victimes
mais l'étape et tout pour les gendarmes
tous les actes nous rien n'est payé pour
nous nous sommes obligés de tout payer
c'est pour ça que aujourd'hui on
continue à se battre et on va demander
cette contre expertise qui va sortir il
ya un mois qui va être faite par quatre
grands imminent médecins qui vont dire
que scientifiquement parlant ce qui a
été fait dans toutes les expertises
avant scientifiquement c'est impossible
c'est même une en sus
au métier d'expert et de médecins karama
traoré n'est morte d'aucune maladie qu
adama traoré bien mort asphyxié
suite aux contrôles subis par les
gendarmes et la halle enquête va être
relancé l'enquêté va repartir
les gendarmes vont être entendu les
témoins vont être entendus et nous
allons nous demandons aujourd'hui en
tout cas la mise en examen du gendarme
parce que nous avons tous les éléments
pour aller un procès voilà comment ça se
passe voilà comment cette machine de
guerre elle est organisée
comment cette machine de guerre elle est
systémique à chaque fois qui a un
coupable qui est un meurtre elles vont
tout de suite sortir leurs armes pour
nous emmener vers un non lieu et nous
criminaliser parce qu'il faut savoir que
en france comme dans d'autres pays
la vie est d'un noir où la vie d'un
arabe où la vie de deux personnes qui
vient d'ailleurs des gens du voyage ne
vaut pas d'être vécue
quand on parle de l'abolition de la
peine de mort c'est faux il ya juste une
passation de pouvoir entre la justice et
la police parce que quand les policiers
nous tue quand les gendarmes nous tue
mais il ne se passe rien c'est plus la
justice qui le dit mais elle est faite
par doute sur le terrain et ça devient
normal comme si nos vies ne valait pas
d'être vécue
mon frère ne devaient pas mourir ce jour
là mon frère il est mort parce qu'il
s'appelle adama traoré mon frère il est
mort parce qu'il était noir
mon frère il est mort parce qu'il
sortait d'un quartier populaire mon
frère il est mort parce qu'il a subi un
contrôle au faciès condamné la france a
été condamnée pour ça c'est ce qui se
passe automatiquement
et ce combat là on le gagnera seulement
quand quand tout le monde quand les gens
auront compris que leur vie et vaut
d'être vécue et que surtout on ne peut
pas les tuer qui peuvent participer à la
construction de ce monde qui peuvent
participer à la construction de leur
propre vie donc je vous remercie
beaucoup
la fin vient d'arriver et un j'espère
qu'on va continuer le combat et ceux qui
connaissaient pas qu'on va aller
ensemble dans le combat justice et
vérité pour adama pour tous les adama
traoré
[Applaudissements]